okay so in this presentation I want to
introduce you to some of the basic
differences and similarities between the
two broad categories of cells called
prokaryotic cells and eukaryotic cells
so let's go ahead and jump right in
we're going to start with the eukaryotic
cells first first of all the eukaryotes
so these cells are typically much more
complex and what makes them more complex
is that their DNA is housed in a
protective nucleus you'll often hear the
definition of a eukaryote is a cell with
membrane bound organelles that's another
reason why they are more complex what do
we mean by membrane bound organelles
well what we mean by that is there's an
outer layer to it kind of like a skin
although maybe skin is not the best use
of words but there's an outer boundary
that allows materials and and allows
materials out
and so in the picture I've highlighted
the mitochondria we're not going to go
through all of these cell parts but the
mitochondria is an example of a
membrane-bound organelle and it makes
energy for the cell and another example
you may have heard of is called the
chloroplast it's what plant cells have
to do photosynthesis this is an animal
cell in the diagram so there are no
chloroplasts in this picture but it also
is a membrane-bound organelle lysosomes
help to digest and break down certain
food particles and they also are
membrane bound the rough and the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum also membrane
bound the rough endoplasmic reticulum
helps in the production of proteins the
smooth endoplasmic reticulum helps to
build up build up fats and lipids the
Golgi apparatus again another example of
a membrane-bound organelle the Golgi
apparatus helps to sort package and
distribute proteins around the cell and
at the bottom here we have a vacuole
which is kind of like the storage
container membrane-bound as well
and so when we look at eukaryotes
they're typically much larger in size
the diagram shows a eukaryotic cell
that's about 20 micrometers in size that
symbol is the abbreviation for
micrometers we're going to come back to
this in a little bit so when we look at
the classification of eukaryotes we
notice that there are many big kingdoms
of life that are considered eukaryotic
the picture shows a member of kingdom
Protista this is an example of an amoeba
they live in pond water they're
single-cell but they are eukaryotes
kingdom fungi I'm sure we've heard of
mushrooms are a great example of kingdom
fungi they feed off of dead organic
matter I'm sure we've all heard of
kingdom plantae also known as plants
plants are photosynthetic and they
obtain their food by by manufacturing
sugars through photosynthesis
and then kingdom Animalia which we are a
member of kingdom a llama animal ei as
well as frogs and so these are the four
big broad categories of life called
kingdoms that are eukaryotic and when we
look at this little diagram here as I
just mentioned a moment ago there are
four of the six kingdoms of life so if
four kingdoms of life are eukaryotic
well what about those other two let's
talk about those next so next I want to
mention the prokaryotes and much less
complex and what makes them less complex
is the fact that they do not have a
nucleus and it's not that they just
don't have a nucleus but they also lack
most of those organelles that we just
went through when you look at the
diagram yes they have a few organelles
in common with eukaryotes ribosomes
cytoplasm the cell the cell wall the
cell membrane but that's really about it
there's not a lot in common that they
have prokaryotes lack membrane bound
organelles no mitochondria no vacuoles
no chloroplasts no Golgi apparatus and
they're but much much smaller in size if
you remember that previous picture of
the eukaryotic cell that was about 20
micrometers in size this one is only
about three and so when we put the cells
side-by-side one another with our scale
here it really is striking just to see
how much larger eukaryotic cells are
versus prokaryote
and when it comes to classification of
prokaryotes here we have our our picture
of the six kingdoms of life and one of
them is labeled Kingdom eubacteria and
the other one is labeled Kingdom our key
bacteria so if you see here there's a
little clue as to what types of
organisms are procured
prokaryotes are better known as
bacterias when we ever we hear the word
bacteria we we are referring to
prokaryotic cells what about their
similarities we just went over their
differences what about their
similarities while prokaryotes and
eukaryotes each have a cell or plasma
membrane that allows materials to come
in and out each has DNA DNA is the
molecule of heredity it's the molecule
that passes genetic genetic information
from generation to generation
each has ribosomes when you look at the
two diagrams that each have ribosomes
that's because they each need proteins
and that's the job of ribosomes is to
build proteins and each has a fluid
interior called the cytoplasm the
cytoplasm is really important because
this is where a lot of the chemical
reactions that take place within a cell
occur so the last thing I want to
briefly mention is the endosymbiosis
theory and prokaryotes also called
bacteria I thought to be the first
inhabitants of Earth and we think that
because we've analyzed their DNA we
found fossils and they appear to be the
oldest fossils and over time we think
that eukaryotes eventually evolved from
them so Protista plants animals and
fungus our ancestors are prokaryotes are
bacteria and as the theory goes
prokaryotic cells are thought to have
devoured and swallowed up what would
eventually become the mitochondria what
would eventually become the chloroplast
and over the years over the billions of
years prokaryotic cells became a little
more different a little more diverse and
that's really a summary of what the
endosymbiosis theory says I I would
encourage you to google it and look at
some of the details it's a pretty
interesting theory but thank you for
joining this quick summary of the
differences between prokaryotes and
eukaryotes please stay tuned for some
acknowledgments
and next I want to acknowledge some of
the photographers who made these some of
these images possible so please I wanted
to to thank the photographers and and
check out some of their work you might
like some of the other work that they
have